hey guys be here today I'm going to do a
character video about Philip Jefferies
Jefferies has always been an interesting
character and I brought him up in quite
a few videos so far this season so I
thought it would be a good idea to go
into his complete history which is as
much since we don't know that much about
him this is your spoiler warning if
you've never seen fire walk with me if
you're not caught up in season three or
if you haven't seen the missing pieces
or read the secret history you're going
to get some bits and pieces from that as
well
either way though he's an important
character and this shouldn't really ruin
anything else it's just his basic back
story so Phillip Jeffries is an agent of
the FBI he was played by David Bowie
which may add a little bit more interest
to his character we first met him in
fire walk with me at the FBI field
office in Philadelphia where he came in
later we found out from secret history
of Twin Peaks that he went through
training in 1968 at Quantico with Gordon
Cole and they graduated as the top two
agents in that graduating class we also
know from the secret history that in
1987 he visited the palm deluxe hotel in
Buenos Aires Argentina we saw in the
missing pieces that he he went up to the
desk at that hotel and he was asking
about Judy Miz Julie I think he referred
to at the time he got a letter from the
guy behind the counter and it turned out
this was left for him by Judy you don't
know who Juhi is joined the club but
we'll talk about her a little bit
towards the end of the video so after he
grabs the letter he goes to the elevator
and basically that's the last time
anybody had seen him two years later
though he comes out of the elevator in
the FBI field office he's wearing the
exact same clothes that he was wearing
ray disappeared two years prior you know
after going into the elevator down in
Argentina and that's where the seam over
initially introduced to him and buyer
walk with me picks up he basically comes
into Gordon Cole's office and Cooper's
there
and Albert is also there he seems pretty
crazy at the time he's rambling about
Judy but he's also saying like we're not
going to talk about about her at the
same time so he brings her up but he's
not talking about her he sees Special
Agent Dale Cooper there who he has not
met previously as far as we know and he
yells who do you think this is there he
done sort of rambles out the story of
where he's been he tells us that he made
some kind of interesting discovery in
Seattle at Judy's that he attended one
of their meetings and it happened above
a convenience store and he mentioned
something about the AL cave ring albert
kind of does albert stuff then doesn't
really help the situation but add some
nice chuckles here and there and him a
cold basically are trying to figure out
what's going on and how Jeffries got
there because this is the FBI
headquarters you can't just walk in the
lights start flickering and that catches
Cooper's attention and he goes back out
to the hallway Jeffries continues to
talk Cole goes over to try to call
people to come in and realizes the
intercoms dead Jeffries notices a
calendar and T's it's February 1989
which is a complete shock to him and
then as Cole turns back around from the
intercom Jeffries just disappears again
in the missing pieces we see that here
Ian in Buenos Aires and we can gather
that this is back in 1987 because it's
the same bellhop that we see there so
that's a little bit confusing a little
bit of time jump there in season three
we start hearing more about Jeffries
which is something that no one really
knew for sure if they would use this
character because of course David Bowie
passed away so evil cooper contacts who
he thinks is Jeffries on the radio that
he carries around in his little
briefcase thing he ends up not thinking
that it's actually Jeffries when he
talks to him and we find out that he had
some kind of deal or something going on
with evil coupe but at the very same
time we find out
he was going behind his back and trying
to get Rey and Daria to kill him and he
was going to pay a half a million
dollars for that later on in season 3 we
hear about him again once when evil
coups in jail he tells Gordon that he's
been working for undercover for the last
20 years or whatever for Jeffries and
that he needs to be debriefed by Gordon
of course that never happens because
they're trying to figure out what's
going on with this guy because they
basically know he's not the real Dale
Cooper then when they go outside Cole
and Albert talked and we find out that
Albert had a a call from Jeffries who
had been missing obviously and it
related to agent Cooper who was also
missing and they told Jeffries wanted to
know about the name of an agent they had
in Colombia that this was important for
the safety of Cooper and then we found
out that that guy who in Colombia ended
up killed I guess the biggest mystery
right now about him is who was evil
Cooper actually talking to at the hotel
in South Dakota the guy on that line you
know he basically said that he knew he
had met with major garland Briggs that
he missed him in New York and so you
know whoever that is is connected to a
lot of the mysterious things that have
been going on in season 3 he also said
that evil coupe was going back in which
meant going back into the lodge and that
this guy would be with Bob again so
that's you know all mysterious stuff but
no matter how you look at it and why
this is important is is because after
ray shot evil coupe he talks to who he
thinks his Jeffries on the phone as he's
driving away he tells them that he
thinks Cooper's dead you know the
doppelganger evil coupe is dead but he
wasn't sure because he had gotten some
help you know we saw that we saw the
woodsman and he just basically said I
don't know what happened he got some
help and I'll finish him off at the farm
if he follows me there so I mentioned in
the secret history video Tammy says that
the last time he's been seen was in
Philadelphia in 1989 and according to
the dates the secret history occurs
after the events in season 3 so we don't
really have expectation of seeing him
show up in pub
as I mentioned you know unfortunately
David Bowie passed away right as they
were beginning to shoot and the actor
who plays Andy actually said in an
interview that David Bowie was supposed
to be in the returned you know it's
supposed to be in the season it was it
was set up that way but because of his
illness and his passing away he didn't
get to shoot any scenes so you know this
guy is a total mystery he was an
interesting character right from the
start and part of that was his casting I
mean if you cast David Bowie in your
movie even though he's not the most
established actor he's a very famous
person so you got to imagine the guy is
an important character right plus he's
connected to all this stuff and the way
that he enters and he leaves and then
whenever the missing pieces came out
afterwards we got more so he was you
know a very fascinating character and
his counterpart Judy also is a complete
kind of mystery like I said he comes in
he says I not going to talk about Judy
but then he brings up that he went to
this meeting above the convenience store
which is a huge part of the mythology
behind the lodges and that convenience
store was supposed to be like he went to
that meeting in relation to Judy when he
was staying with her in Seattle now as
far as Kane is concerned that's all we
really know about her except that we did
have that scene in the lodge where we
see a monkey interestingly enough to
mouth the name Judy and I'm not going to
go into a whole big rabbit hole there
but yeah we hear her name there now
non-canon wise like stuff that doesn't
really mean much other than it's out
there was that initially according to
the early versions of the script
I guess Judy had been identified as
Josie's sister Josie from the original
series since that part didn't make it
into the final script there's no saying
for sure that that's true but it's
interesting because Joe and Chen who
played Josie decided but whenever the
announcement I guess probably in 2015
when it was announced the Showtime was
going to bring Twin Peaks back she wrote
a letter to David Lynch in character and
she mentioned
in that letter as her twin sister so
apparently you know she was she was
doing a kind of as a joke but you have
to figure that she was wanting to be
involved in the series you know season
three and she was kind of floating it
out there that she could come back and
play her twin sister if Josie herself
would stay trapped in the wood at the
Great Northern so Phillip Jeffries is
going to play a part one way or another
whether it's actually Jefferies or if it
turns out to be someone who's a you know
taking his identity what that's going to
be is not exactly clear but since I've
been talking about the secret history a
lot this week
it seems relevant that a lot of the
times that we see to Gordon that were
added in that book are gonna you know
they're gonna some of that stuff's going
to see more light of day so I think
through that we'll probably learn some
interesting stuff about Geoffrey's
character and hopefully when the final
dossier comes out we'll get to the final
dossier says it's going to be to fill in
the gaps of what happened with
characters in the last 25 years
hopefully we'll get some more Phillip
Jeffries there because he's fascinating
entity it kind of sucks well it doesn't
kind of suck it absolutely sucks that
David Bowie wasn't able to reprise his
role and you know there was a rumor
before that whenever they made fire walk
with me they had an idea where they were
going to do another prequel where it was
going to be all about Jeffries and his
adventures I guess but since fire walk
with me didn't get great reviews or
great you know acclaim at the time they
kind of shell tall that and this is
probably the you know what this is what
we have to work with so let me know in
the comments what you think please like
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel and check back
soon because we're almost there it's
almost time to end this hiatus and pick
up with episode 9 thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon